okay, let's get into audience questions for
the week.
Very timely one.
Hey David, even if the Joe Biden's conspiracy
isn't literally true, as Republicans say,
isn't it still extraordinarily corrupt that
Joe Biden's son, Hunter Biden is working for
a Ukrainian gas company and getting paid $50,000
a month?
So yes, I mean he, here's what you have to
distinguish and this is so, so I'm going to
take the question as being a good faith question
because I do see a lot of bad faith, right
wing actors saying the real corruption is
Biden's son.
And then I also see some good faith left way
actors saying, wait a second, I am reading
that it is corrupt.
What was going on with Joe Biden and Hunter
Biden in Ukraine?
So here's the deal.
We have a system that is a system built on
the status quo, revolving door, business,
politics, lobbying, cronyism, consultancy,
that that's the, the system that we have.
And in this system, you have a King makers
in politics and lobbyists and elected officials
and campaign consultants and all of these
fo bogus consultancy positions that are made
available to connected people, not because
of their knowledge or skills, but because
of their connections like that exists.
And that's a thing.
So I'll give you an example.
Paul Ryan, the former Republican speaker of
the house.
As I mentioned earlier this week, is now on
the board of Fox news.
What does Paul Ryan really know about being
on the board of a media company?
It will, you can say, well, he did deal with
the FCC as a member of Congress or this or
that or whatever.
The other thing, but this is just an example
of what we are talking about.
It is the revolving door of people between
politics and industry and [inaudible], all
of that sort of stuff.
So when you see Joe Biden, uh, having a son,
Hunter Biden who's getting paid reportedly
50 grand a month to be an advisor or whatever
to this, uh, Ukrainian gas company, it is
absolutely an example of the money buys you
money and connections get you connections
and money status quo that we have.
It is an example of that.
It is not any particularly acute instance
of what Joe Biden is being accused of, which
should change the focus of the entire story
from what Donald Trump did in withholding
hundreds of millions of dollars in aid, in
exchange for Ukraine, agreeing to smear Joe
Biden.
That should be the focus.
The suppression of the whistleblowers should
be the focus.
So there's that angle.
It's also particularly hypocritical for Trump
to be the one calling it out because Trump
is the King of these types of cronies to corrupt
instances.
So do I have a problem with what it is that
Hunter Biden was doing?
Yes.
In the same way that hundreds and hundreds
of relatives, friends, former politicians,
et cetera, et cetera, are in these positions
because that's how our system is built.
It is endemic corruption and cronyism and
it needs to be changed at the systemic level.
But the specific conspiracy that is being
built around Joe Biden and Hunter Biden and
Joe Biden's saying, Oh, Hunter's in trouble
cause this company's being investigated.
Let me get out there and start making some
threats over bank guarantees.
It's not the way it went down.
It's been widely debunked and it's just not
anything that the facts can defend.
And that's why we need to be particularly
careful about, there's a, a, an immediate
Republicans don't care about this revolving
door status quo of lobbyists and politicians
and family members and all of this stuff.
They love it.
Okay.
And for them to now say, Oh, the real problem
is that the son of a vice president was making
a bunch of money as a consultant here, and
then Joe Biden went out to save his ass.
They don't really care about this as an issue
and they're only using this hypocritically
I might add to distract from the real chaos,
the real story, which is Trump's suppression
of the whistleblower and the demand that Donald
Trump on Ukraine.
So yeah, we'll talk about it in the sense
that we talk about the whole system as it
works, but the acute story here is the one
related to Donald Trump's actions.